feel like you've seen Mandy from Young
Sheldon before maybe you've seen her in
other sitcoms or kids movies or even a
few sitcoms for kids in season five of
young Sheldon viewers were first
introduced to Mandy a 30 year old woman
who meets Sheldon Cooper's older brother
Georgie at the laundromat owned by the
boys's fun-loving grandmother while it
definitely wasn't love at first sight
their relationship matures and Mandy
eventually becomes pregnant which adds a
fun dramatic Flair to the sitcom prequel
Mandy quickly becomes part of the family
with their daughter Constance who was
named after Sheldon and Georgie's Memaw
Connie before taking on the role of the
quick-witted Mandy on young Sheldon
Emily Osmond the younger sister of The
Sixth Sense star Haley Joel Osment was
featured in a few other sitcoms and even
a series of action-packed films while
she also appeared in her share of
dramatic projects her performance as
Mandy showcases the comedic acting chops
she's been developing since her youth
some of her earliest roles were guest
appearances on Third Rock From the Sun
and friends her first truly notable role
was in the original Spy Kids film series
where she portrayed Gertie Giggles
rocking Unforgettable helicopter
pigtails that allowed the youngster to
fly Gertie debuted in Spy Kids 2 island
of Lost Dreams as the super spy younger
sister of the antagonistic Gary she
starts as a competitive villain and
possible love interest for protagonist
Juni Cortez before eventually seeing the
corruption within her own family Osman
returned as Gertie for Spy Kids 3 game
Over where her Fantastical hairstyle
made a fabulous comeback she appeared to
encourage Juni to take up the family
business as an agent once again you
might also recognize Osman from her role
as Lily Truscott on the smash hit series
Hannah Montana the show became a
worldwide sensation with Osment playing
the best friend of Pop Superstar Hannah
Montana Osment superb sense of community
timing shines through as she plays off
series lead Miley Cyrus and a plethora
of laughable situations she even gets a
chance to play a heightened version of
her character through the clownish alter
ego Lola wearing a variety of bob cut
neon wigs the chemistry between the two
young Stars helped Propel Hannah Montana
to extraordinary success coincidentally
the two even had their own guest
starring roles on the raunchy comedy Two
and a Half Men Emily Osment showed off
her goofier side in the coming-of-age
hit Young and Hungry As the striving
personal Chef Gabby Diamond contrary to
her last name things don't always go as
smoothly as the youthful cook would like
leading to a series of memorable Antics
Young and Hungry highlights the best
qualities of Osmond's acting history
with slapstick comedy sarcastic
comebacks and relatable young adult
situations as she navigates life in San
Francisco with her zany friends the
sitcom was a fresh start for ABC family
as it transitioned into the the trendy
freeform Network the Forward Thinking
series helped shift the landscape
towards the New Vision with fellow
former Disney Channel star Ashley
Tisdale occupying both the producer role
and a recurring part as a guest star in
the series the two even shared a few
ridiculous scenes together
my mom used to do this to me when I talk
too much I just wanted to change the
subject
mom never did that Osman also lent her
talents to the heartwarming Netflix
comedy pretty smart as the snarky
Brainiac Chelsea fans may even see
shades of Sheldon Cooper here as her
character is extremely similar Osment
stars as Claire's rigid older sister who
moves in with her and her friends in Los
Angeles the show cleverly balances
Chelsea's overachieving academic life
with her sisters more Carefree attitude
at first the two seemingly couldn't be
more different before they inevitably
discover their similarities and grow
closer as sisters Osmond's knack for
snarky remarks comes in handy here as
she adapts to the influencers paradise
she also captures her character's Kinder
moments with authenticity she even has a
romantic will they won't they
relationship with previous Disney
Channel star Greg sulkin's character
Grant which gives pretty smart an added
dose of nostalgia fans will surely enjoy
unfortunately the Cozy and color careful
series was canceled after only one
season though you can still visit this
heartfelt tale anytime on Netflix
[Music]
foreign